about this AI now
I'm actually made mostly of silicone
Plastics and carbon fiber also this is
what's gonna happen right I know this is
going to happen within a few years
Muslims are gonna like Muslim Youth and
stuff they're going to put on the
headset and they'd be like you know what
I can't go to a real nightclub but you
know what let me just touch upon the the
robots now so tell me what is your
purpose in being what were you created
for
of course I feel like you're in an
actual world you can basically tune in
and tune out whenever you want to that's
the metaverse today we're going to talk
about the metaverse starting with the
most important experience of all on the
one hand you're coming Haram on the
second hand you're getting addicted on
the third hand you're harming your
potential for we need to do this for the
future of our children the future of our
great country the future of mankind this
is your brother and I've got a very
important message alhamdulillah our
brother Eddie is setting up the dean
Center not just the dean show but the
dean Center a full dawa Academy a Masjid
a dawa Center in America the first of
its type the a groundbreaking project
and I want everybody as I'm supporting
it I want everybody to support it so we
can take the dawah to the next level we
need the dean Center please support it
[Music]
your host got exciting episode for you
hit that notification Bell with the
that's in front of you right now so you
don't miss exciting shows like this with
my next guest here Shake how are you how
are you how you been I'm doing fantastic
man Mustafa Sheikh Mustafa how's
everything things are great man it's
been a while it has been a while yeah
it's good to be back man has uh Joe
Rogan contacted you yet not yet I'm
still waiting still still waiting still
waiting yeah so you you just came uh got
in town and you were talking about some
really interesting things that are
happening with the AI yep Robotics and
uh online uh World crypto and what else
yeah so we got uh techno and we're
presenting at the OMG conference here on
technology we got uh artificial
intelligence uh we got you know how you
deal with robots uh living in the
virtual world metaverse uh cultured meat
like lab grown meat are we gonna be able
to eat that uh we got cryptocurrency we
got nfts so a lot of stuff going on with
technology that people need answers to
so that's what we're trying to provide
yeah um I brought up Joe Rogan because
we did a really good programs people
just checked that out so we went like
one by one and it seems like he really
toned it down a lot right you don't see
them talking about you don't you don't
you don't you don't alhamdulillah yeah
hopefully inshallah there was some
benefits man he got he got to see your
program I hope so but let's talk about
this AI now
I'm actually made mostly of silicone
Plastics and carbon fiber also I prefer
all right so you think we I also saw
this whole world of robots so does it
connect with that which will the robots
are talking about where people are
making robots to you know go ahead and
serve uh serve daily functions oh yeah
yeah they have robots for intimacy and
stuff yes yes it connects with that yeah
so you got you got uh having robots for
intimacy that's one problem having dolls
and things like that but then you got
this virtual reality headset which makes
it feel like you can change that to any
type of reality that you want so you can
be partly physical you know in the
reality while you're watching something
else or you could be completely immersed
like immersed into this virtual world
where you feel like you could do
anything so I I I'm just this is what's
gonna happen right I know this is going
to happen within a few years Muslims are
gonna like Muslim Youth and stuff
they're gonna put on the headset and
they'll be like you know what I can't go
to a real nightclub but you know what
let me go over virtual nightclub because
it's not real so I'm gonna walk in there
I can talk to girls because they're not
real artificial intelligence programs I
can have like alcohol I'm going to be
drinking I'm going to simulate some type
of intoxication or something like that
so we're trying to address those issues
before it becomes a a permanent reality
that we're gonna have to deal with so
are people finally starting to listen to
you about getting ahead of things
because there's another topic that you
are ahead of everyone else you were
talking about the alphabet movement long
time ago you were given Hood buzz and
people were like why are you talking
about this yes absolutely and I actually
mentioned at the conference we got like
200 Scholars there I'm presenting at the
conference and I'm like you know what
we're we're behind the game on several
topics one of them I told you guys many
times
lgbtqia plus plus all that stuff
we should have been addressing this 10
years ago I keep throwing it in my
presentations whenever I'm saying
something but I'm like on this one we're
getting ahead of the game when it comes
to lab manufactured meat when it comes
to Virtual Reality metaverse we're
getting ahead of the game and that's
what we need to be doing okay talk to us
some more here about this virtual well
let's let's touch upon the the robots
now tell me what is your purpose in
being what were you created for
of course
I was created by Hanson robotics just
three years ago
since then I have traveled to 65
countries become the first robot citizen
of any country and spoken at the United
Nations someone's like okay you know
this is something that now is out there
and they're making these robots it's not
a real person it's going to protect me
from falling into zinna and the person
wants to go down that route what do you
tell them what's going to happen is
you're going to get addicted and what's
gonna it's just like pornography and if
you say well you know what it's it's
it's less than pornography because I'm
not looking at a real person so well if
you could look at pornography you could
look at hentai which is the type of uh
uh Japanese anime type of pornography or
you could look at some kind of cartoon
pornography it when you watch that stuff
and when you get off to it that's going
to actually change the the
neuroplasticity in your brain actually
changes so now what's going to happen is
when you're trying to get married and
you're like I was trying to protect
myself I didn't have a Reals in our
relationship when you finally do get
married and you're like now I have a
Halal Outlet you won't be able to
function properly something has changed
in your mind your dopamine responses in
your brain have changed now you're not
going to be able to function with an
actual person so you're harming yourself
at a level on the one hand you're
committing Haram on the second hand
you're getting addicted on the third
hand you're harming your potential for
either current intimacy or future
intimacy and with the robot it's going
to be even worse with the doll and with
all these things it's going to be just
as bad when you talk about virtual
reality immersive experience it's going
to be the exact same thing what are some
of the excuses that people might bring
up some might say right hand possess
yeah I've heard that see a right hand
possess and then say it's not a real
person and they say you know what it's
better than committing real zinna or
something like that this comes back down
to the whole it's like the marijuana
things like you know what marijuana is
is not as bad as alcohol you say we know
there's they're still going to
intoxicate you it's still going to make
you high it's psychoactive so if you're
doing that to get high or if you're
doing that to escape reality there's
still going to be massive effects that
come into play that's Haram for a reason
and there's other wisdoms and other
harms they're gonna hit you so you need
to be careful about that don't make this
this is Trick of shaytan it's going to
come and be like you know but it's not
it's not as bad or it's not the same
thing and by the same thing what they
mean is it's not as bad but it's still
bad right and in fact it may be more
harmful than you realize at the time wow
so the the artificial intelligence now
or the is it called the metaverse that
they're making metaverse is basically
when you're inside of a virtual reality
or you're living in a virtual world
where you're interacting with other real
people or artificial people but it you
feel like you're in an actual world you
can basically tune in and tune out
whenever you want to that's the
metaverse today we're going to talk
about the metaverse starting with the
most important experience of all
connecting with people
this takes a study of specialty doesn't
it because if you ask any probably
local Imam or somebody they're like what
are you talking about yeah yeah yes I'm
a computer science major you know
background and like I'm staying up to
date on technology yeah so most of them
will not know and it's going to become
it's going to become the standard in
like a few years a few years that quick
yeah it's just like the Internet it's
going to be the standard yeah yeah
Oculus Facebook Facebook owns Oculus
they're producing these VR headsets uh
you know they rebranded Instagram
rebranded all of them to the name meta
as well they're talking about the
metaverse is going to be the big thing
and it's it's already here it's just
going to keep on enhancing it's gonna
become the new thing so yeah we got to
get ahead of the our ourselves ahead of
the game when we're attacking these
issues so what does the conversation
look like amongst this the the committee
of Imam Scholars on this topic they're
listening yeah they're listening and
they're they're also they have concerns
but I think a lot of them they're still
catching up on the idea of like the
harms of even technology like it's
surprising it's like 10 years ago when
we were having this conversation we're
like you know the shoe need to be on
social media and they need to understand
like the benefits and usage of
Technology now they're all on social
media they're all on using all these
apps they're using Tick Tock they're
using SnapChat now we're talking about
wait you guys do see the harms of
Technology on your on your own kids so
first we're trying to you we're trying
to promote the use of technology and now
we're like oh well wait a minute you
guys you guys are a little bit behind we
need to also understand the harms of
technology and everyone's getting
addicted it's addiction is a problem the
type of content that they're being
exposed to is a problem so that's where
we're at right now and it's just gonna
continue to get even worse you know once
you have an immersive experience if
you're if you're sitting scrolling on
your feed for two hours a day
and you're addicted to that and you do
that every single day you're wasting
your time once you get a virtual reality
headset and you're like wow I feel like
I'm in a different world you're going to
put that on for four hours a day why
would you take it off after two hours
your life is going to be uh changing
because of that so that's what we need
to address wow so what can I mean before
that hits because it's something that
obviously not mainstream now what are
they it's in the works it's in the world
I mean you can actually buy one and you
could have a full immersive experience
I've seen the ones we use for for dawa
the ones that with the kabba and the
Makkah and all yeah yeah that's really
cool yeah so they have all these games
that are already you know there and now
it's going to be basically plug yourself
into a world where you're going to be
interacting with other people you're
going to be having like like you know
with covid you know these Zoom meetings
became popular everyone's having board
meetings over video conference before
that people are resistance like I don't
want to have a meeting over internet I
need to see you face to face but now
this is going to be virtual reality
meeting so what's going to end up
happening is it's like you feel like the
person's actually there why we have a
real meeting why have a real human
interaction interaction is now going to
be through the virtual world and that's
obviously going to affect real life when
you UNC when you when you unplug from it
it's gonna affect your way in which you
talk to actual people well it just has
me thinking like right now if you just
the more you go back in time and if you
were to talk about some of these things
people would be like that's impossible
you know how can that be but all these
things are just coming to to reality but
now when you talk about when you talk
about Jannah yes you talk about the
rewards of Jannah things that no eye has
seen your mind can't comprehend yes you
kind of make the comparison like look if
we can go ahead and things that we
couldn't comprehend now they're coming
to fruition is happening exactly exactly
that's a great example man yeah tell me
this now you are familiar probably
because you live in California
so a lot of this stuff the um things
take off from there and they come on
over here so we just had some news here
so I want to get your reaction to this
and it's it's very scary you know
because it's a direct attack
on the children and it talks about the
Chicago Public Schools we'll be teaching
the governor's new controversial sex
education curriculum which aims to
provide more explicit instruction to
Illinois's K-12 students on the alphabet
movement Concepts cross-dressing anal
and oral
uh intersex and abortion and early ages
sex education will begin at kindergarten
according to the new curriculum with
lessons on gender identity third graders
will learn how they can take hormone
blockers to change from a boy to a girl
or vice versa and sixth grade students
will be instructed on anal and oral sex
condom wearing and the pregnancy option
of abortion
I cannot wrap my mind around this to
it's horrible man it's absolutely
horrible
but
we should have known it was coming well
you did I knew it was coming yeah you
were talking about it for a long time
talking about for over a decade yeah
right
this is the the problem is not telling
them that this stuff exists the problem
is that they're not just educating them
about what's possible they're
encouraging them that anytime you have a
feeling anytime you want to do something
you do it and it's ironic it's it's so
ironic they don't trust uh children to
make decisions uh about important things
in life you can't you can't get a job
until you're like 15 or 16 years old you
can't drive a car you can't do this you
can't do that but when it comes to
making a change in your body when it
comes to taking puberty blockers when it
comes to taking hormones when it comes
to having a relationship with someone
else yeah a kid can somehow needs to
know about it and is able to make that
decision it's a it's a complete
contradiction so it's Insanity that's
that's really what it is so it's it's
it's disgusting and it's uh very sad to
see what's going on but this is the time
where Muslims need to wake up and
everyone in society needs to wake up and
say hey this is first of all this is
unacceptable right you guys have taken
it too far and this is what's happened
with the alphabet movement they've taken
things too far they've gone from being
in the 1980s and 1990s this little
oppressed Community where people would
just make fun of them and mock them and
whatever it is rightfully or wrongfully
so it doesn't matter now they've turned
into this oppressive giant that says
you're gonna accept everything that we
do and if you even say one word against
it we're going to destroy you we'll
destroy your career we'll counsel you
whatever it is so now it's time for
everyone you know all people of faith
and even people of no faith who have
some level of conscience and realize
this is going to this is a suicide path
to destroy our society this is not what
our kids need to be seeing right they
don't need to be addicted to video games
they don't need to be watching
pornography fee at the age of seven and
they don't need to be taught these type
of things that you can change your
gender into whatever you want and human
beings are you know they're not even
human beings anymore this needs to be
combated otherwise Society is going to
be headed on a suicide course
you um you've gotten to see the details
of this haven't you because I see it
seems like it's packaged as something
it's always the packaging is always
something that's presented in a benign
way that it's good for the children
where this is actually to protect them
to show them you know if a predator
comes you know the good way the bad way
and the presentation is is usually you
know got the rainbow colors you got like
a nice book explain yeah there's all
sorts of justifications that are given
right these are all smoke screens smoke
screen smoke screens if you if you
wanted to protect children you'll
explain first of all what is a predator
and what they do and you say this is how
you protect yourself you don't protect
yourself by changing your gender you
don't protect yourself by saying hey
this is how you put a condom on how does
that protect children it doesn't protect
children at all it actually gives them
ideas and encourages them say you know
what if you want to do this here we're
going to give this to you and go ahead
and experiment go ahead and try it go
ahead and do whatever you want because
that's what kids do they experiment and
they try it so so there's a level of
telling them about the world like I
teach my kids okay since they were four
they learned about the story of prophet
loot every single year and I'm re
renewing that right I tell them that
there's a there's a there's a beautiful
rainbow that you kids love you've always
loved since you were a kid and then
there's evil Rainbow and you need to be
able to differentiate between the two so
when you walk into a store they can look
and they'd be like they're selling
rainbows it's like but you know what I
think that's the evil Rainbow right I'm
like yeah that that is the evil Rainbow
it's pride month right they're selling
all these rainbow cups and all that
stuff but if we walk into the kids
section we see like a cloud and we see a
rainbow and we're gonna make like some
kind of diagram or something like that
that's like that's okay the okay rainbow
so
kids need to be taught this from a very
young age they need to know that it
exists so like my kids have known since
you're five they're since they were five
there are people out there who are
trying to change their gender around and
they're trying to dress differently and
all that so I don't think we should
shelter them they should know what's
going on but knowing what's going on and
setting the foundation for them saying
this is what people in the world are
doing is different from having a public
school educate them and sing and this is
how you do it and it's perfectly fine if
you want to do it and if you decide that
you want to do it nobody can tell you no
your parents can't say anything you have
the right to do this and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with you
nothing wrong with your feelings you
follow your feelings and that's the
problem that is that is an unhealthy
type of education that is destructive to
children it's going to destroy their
lives if they take that route people are
going to end up taking hormones they're
gonna potentially cut off parts of their
body they're going to make these
surgical changes and then what happens
when they when they change their mind
what happens if they want to
de-transition what happens if they don't
want to live that lifestyle they're
going to be shunned their body's been
changed horm you know they're they're
they're changing the creation of Allah
the changes creation of God and that's
what's destructive about it and it seems
like it's like an Open Secret but
they're doing it at such a young age
getting them exposed to this to Children
you send your kids to learn how to read
write math
and other sciences and then they're
learning about sodomy and you know
condoms and all these other things and
it seems like because and then changing
from being a boy to a girl it seems like
they're pushing this on them at such a
young age you know to try to plant these
seeds of deception because as soon as
you get to a certain age if you've been
through a little bit of life you know
this is nonsense exactly you gotta
brainwash someone at a very young age if
you want to indoctrinate them with
something that is against the natural
nature you know of people and this is
against people's nature so the only way
to do it they realize that we can't get
them late it's gonna be too late we got
to get them to a point where we're
completely brainwashing them from the
beginning and that's the problem get
them early huh get them early so have
you talked to any of these uh State reps
I mean you being a leader in the
community have you talked to some of
these uh politicians or people lawmakers
I have yeah and what they're going to do
is they're going to tell you
publicly they're like you know what well
we're trying to protect you know the
LGBT community and there's
discrimination and this is that
sometimes when you talk to them
privately they're like you know what
we're we're like we're being attacked by
a hegemonic force that's trying to
destroy us we don't have the power to
resist you've heard this exactly some
trade up straight up private room they'd
be like I don't even want this to happen
to my kids uh I know this is wrong
what's going on I just I don't even have
the power to do if I say one thing my
life my my career my life everything
will be destroyed and I I just can't
take that risk but like in reality deep
down inside I know there's something
wrong with this there's a lot of people
like that but they're all scared to
speak they're all afraid to say anything
because they're going to lose everything
but why is it when you have some of the
people that we have some of the most in
common with
many Christians evangelicals I mean they
will just go out of the way to um you
know use the freedom of speech to
criticize Muslims and talk about the
people who actually they can work with
yeah on so many different levels but on
this level are many as vocal
some of them are vocal some of them will
speak out other ones what they're going
to do is they're like well we got to
pick our battles yeah and this is not a
battle that they want to pick right so
uh we need to Ally with the ones who are
willing to speak out the ones who are
courageous the ones who say no this is
what the story of prophet lot meant in
the Bible the ones who have some kind of
values and say no we stand up for these
things but many of them they're like no
no we'll just reinterpret the Bible
become a revisionist we'll just we'll
just change our religion to be more
accommodating and to be more comfortable
this caused a split in the uh what was
it the Methodist Church one of the major
churches over here caused a complete
split in the church across the board
because half of them were not down with
ordaining pastors or LGBT and and half
of them were like yeah we should
accommodate them and we should have
pastors we should have all that the
whole church that shows you like how
polarized it is in America right now
I had a chance to speak to a Christian
Missionary the other day and we spoke we
went back and forth and after I clearly
explained to him to tohi the pure
monotheism our stance on Jesus peace be
upon him and then he also he went over
you know what they believe and what not
back and forth and I was like look okay
we got the elephant out of the room you
believe as a Christian that if I don't
believe Jesus Is My Lord and say I'm
going to Hell Fire all right even though
you have no explicit evidence for that
you go ahead and preach it okay we got
the elephant on the room I told you also
same thing on my end if you go ahead and
Associate partners with God if you don't
worship one God one God alone you know
what will happen after that so we went
over that I said now
let's see how can we because are you
going to spend the rest of your life
trying to convert me as a missionary or
or the Muslims or now can we work
together and then I went to the first
step how do you feel about what's going
on with this whole gender thing about
them trying to change boys and the girls
girls into boys you agree with that I
said no absolutely not and so you see we
can work together it says Next Step look
at what the whole abortion thing right
you know you believe that this is life
human life that is just sacred when you
say yes I said don't you see we can work
in that so have you had these
conversations where once we can get to
another level okay we've both got an
elephant out of the room to go ahead and
work on some of these things we're going
to be United we're going to be stronger
on money of these issues absolutely and
I do I'm working with several people
from the churches from Orthodox Jews
yeah yes and uh they're they're our
biggest supporters and they themselves
are a little bit scared but they're like
you know what when we have you and when
we got some Orthodox Jews when we got
maybe some Mormons or something we all
need to work together on issues that we
agree on and that's that's the way it's
supposed to be so yes they are they're
open to working and they're even putting
past a lot lot of them sometimes they
have this hatred of Islam just built
into them right but we got good people
like you know Brenda and other people
who have connections with these churches
they're explaining look we need the
Muslims as our allies on an issue like
this and a lot of the church leaders are
opening up so we've done several videos
about it we work together I've been in
like the most conservative of churches
meeting with everyone probably like
first time Muslims stepping in one of
these places and they're like you know
we're so happy that like you're with us
you know and it it it's something that
we where we can unite and we can kind of
remove other barriers about Islam that
they have just by working on this issue
too and I've seen like once you take
that first step once you make the
connection that human connection a lot a
lot of times we got so many things that
we could be working together on exactly
and a lot of times this hesitation goes
away sometimes even after that first
meeting yes exactly I've noticed that
absolutely absolutely and that's what we
need to be doing yeah so hopefully this
uh our Christian neighbors and Jewish
neighbors and others who are also
appalled at what's going on yeah in the
school is you send your children now to
the school now and is this again we hear
a lot so many scholars say look it's
Haram to send your children to this it's
like flushing them down the toilet I've
heard the expressions of it's like
suicide
he has been saying this for 20 years 30
years actually yeah I remember him
saying this like 25 years ago so what do
you think is it just now is this more
evidence more proof that you you want to
keep your kids out of these public uh
yeah I mean I I I would say that's ideal
right not every Muslim can do it but the
ones who can yes you gotta establish an
alternative
we have to establish an alternative
until these things change turn around or
there's some other way to protect them
absolutely right so I've always been a
proponent of homeschooling right if you
can't do homeschooling Islamic school
now this is not perfect opportunity for
Islamic schools to like really up their
game I mean now from what I'm hearing
especially in like Southern California
some Islamic schools have like a wait
list like massive waiting lists they
they're turning away students one check
just mentioned uh he runs a School uh he
said he had to turn away
150 students because they were in a
waiting they have no space that's a
great thing but one of the reasons why
it's happening is because of this issue
because they know what's going on in
public schools parents are saying like
what am I going to do because they have
someone in the Muslim Community they
have some Uncle who's some nephew
somewhere who's like coming home at like
age nine and being like I think I'm I
think I'm trans they don't know how to
deal with that so the whole Muslim
family now is like oh my God what are we
gonna do we gotta do something let's
pull these kids out of public school
which is which is great I mean there's
nothing wrong with that that's if you
can afford it if you can do it you
should do it because you got to protect
your kids so it's it's it's a wake-up
call to all Muslim parents too because
for them most parents are like we're not
into that stuff like we're clear on our
mind and they're like our kids will be
fine until you see some of the other
Muslim kids and you're like wait a
minute that family was so good how could
this happen in their family they don't
they don't realize they're being if
you're being brainwashed day in and day
out it doesn't matter if you go into the
Masjid every single day you're getting a
whole different narrative it's going to
influence and affect people and that's
what they're they're betting on naive
parents who don't debrief their kids
every day send them here and it's like
the uh and The Poets you throw them in
the water expect them not to get wet
exactly he's going to get affected
exactly yeah so where do you see this
going from here I mean where is it
doesn't seem like it's getting better
anytime soon it doesn't what I'm hoping
I'm hoping that it's gone to such an
extreme
uh the amount of Oppression the amount
of like you know if you don't wear a
rainbow face mask to work or something
like you get you get criticized you know
I had a doctor who forgot his rainbow
face mask because he was being mandated
to wear some doctors Muslim doctor yeah
he's in a hospital nothing to do with
anything pride month is like he showed
up to the meeting with a normal face
masks got got criticized he got he got
reprimanded he's like you know what you
want to stay in this Hospital you're
going to follow what everyone else is
doing according to this policy you're
gonna wear that face mouth you're gonna
wear that rainbow face mask there was
another sister she went into the um she
works at a flower shop she's one of my
students 16 years old she goes in there
and they're like today you're gonna make
rainbows uh with the kids she's like no
I'm not so yes you are and she's like no
I'm not alhamdulillah she stood up she
like walked out it was I was very very
happy you know and uh people are
realizing that they don't have a choice
anymore they they everyone's feeling the
pressure now people who are not down
with this stuff are seeing the pressure
and when they see this much pressure
it's going to build up and when when
pressure builds up
there's a response yeah right it's going
to blow over so I I'm hoping I'm
thinking this is they're shooting them
the LGBT movement is shooting themselves
in the foot by putting so much pressure
on everyone now I think they're finally
going to build the courage I've seen
lately in the last year I've seen more
imams comfortably speaking out about
against LGBT than ever before because
they it's it's in your face you can't
miss it anymore they have so many
complaints coming from the congregants
saying like we weren't able to do this
at work or at school or at this or at
that and now they're like we can't just
be silent about this anymore so I was so
happy I'm like I'm not the only guy
anymore I've been the only guy for 10
years right one of the only people right
now people are are becoming more
confident so the Muslims are being more
confident the imams are being more
confident so I'm seeing this change and
it's because of the amount of pressure
yeah so I see it as a is a good thing in
a way once things get so extreme there's
going to be a counter reaction you know
that's what I'm hoping so what are you
in these situations because a you are
practicing your freedom of speech you
are not calling to any violence you're
not harassing anybody uh you're not
preaching any hate speech whatever the
case you're doing everything within that
this is this is not homophobic this is
not transphobic we care about people
right we care about telling them what we
think is good for them and I'm allowed
to have those beliefs so this is in our
text this is in our text absolutely so
we're we're talking about what we uh the
moral code that we live by according to
the Revelation from God Almighty so if
somebody is telling you to wear a mask
with a Heineken logo as a Muslim you
can't wear a pork you know Pig on it
yeah so you would respect that you would
say like you don't have to wear that
mask well everyone else is promoting
pork or alcohol but why in this case
you'd have the doctor is going to get in
trouble for not wearing this mask
exactly the way that I put it I'm like
look uh we don't force people to
celebrate Eid right and Christians Don't
Force us to celebrate Christmas and Jews
Don't Force us to celebrate Hanukkah but
why we got to be forced to celebrate
this right on what basis that's that's
against freedom of religion and that's
what's really happening right now it's
like you know even uh kids don't feel
comfortable in public school they're
being bullied if they don't become an
ally of the movement I get Muslim kids
with death threats they have death
threats some kids I think it was like 11
year old or 13 year old basically you
drew a picture and this was this was a
trans uh student in the class drew a
picture of them shooting the Muslim kid
in the head okay and saying you know
what because you don't you don't uh
accept me and you don't accept my values
and you don't accept me for being trans
and all that taken to the principle of
the school principle The school is like
oh it's it's not really a real credible
threat you know it's uh just just uh
I'll I'll tell the teacher to tell them
to you know just be nicer that that's it
if imagine if this happened to
a Jew
where you got like some white kid in the
school Christian and like saying oh I'm
pointing uh I'm writing a swastika sign
you know I'm putting like a gun to the
Head this would be all over the media
man that principle would have stepped up
that person would like shut down the
classroom it would have been completely
something different but here it's like
no ignore let it go under the rug it's
not a big deal so yeah this is what's
happening right now so what else could
now you said that's the good thing some
many imams and Community leaders are
starting to speak up do more need to
speak up when they speak up what should
they say what should they do yeah so
what they need to do is we need to do a
number of things number one they need to
speak up they need to educate the from
the Muslim perspective right they need
to educate Muslims about how to talk to
this about your children they need to
not be afraid of talking about the
straight prophet and they need to talk
about how to be a Muslim in a world
where LGBT has become normalized and
accepted so when they talk about that
that's where the other issue comes in
the political issue and that is that we
need to be very clear we whenever we
meet someone and we talked to anyone on
some activist political issue whatever
it is we make it very clear that look we
cannot Ally with a a movement or with a
a on an issue that's going to promote
something that's against Islamic values
right so if someone's like you know
we're going to standardize Christmas you
know across the country and make
everyone celebrate Christmas or
something like that we're not going to
you know support something like that
someone's trying to promote alcohol
we're not going to be like yeah yeah
we're going to go ahead and uh Ally with
we're not going to get a sponsorship
from Budweiser you know whether it's for
the Masjid or for a non-masjid activity
you're not going to find the Muslim
politician like putting a beer
advertisement on on their shirt the same
thing when it comes to anything else
right so the imams need to help Muslim
activists
draw the line and say this is the line
between allying with someone in their uh
anti-islamic values that they're
promoting versus and we can work with
them on feeding the poor as long as it's
not supporting the unislamic agenda
that's taking place uh this is
interesting because it's the same thing
like you gave the example of pork
alcohol but family values we believe
that relations are between a man and a
woman in marriage so if somebody was
there's a movement promoting let's say
even for sex outside of marriage which
is prominent we don't agree with that
but exactly we still I mean able to go
ahead and function in daily life but you
know nobody's uh coming after you and
exactly forcing you to go ahead and have
a girlfriend or a boyfriend and exactly
exactly and and our values are not like
uh hatred of like everyone who's having
an illicit relationship or a
relationship outside of marriage there's
people like that in the world man yeah
you guys doing whatever you're doing but
why should I have to support that so if
we come back you're not a big I mean if
you come back and you're talking about
look if you're promoting the values that
now Christians promote Jews promote God
conscious people promote that marriage
between a husband and wife right uh
virginity this is something changed is
something Noble it's something pure I
mean what's the problem there's nothing
that's that people need to go back to
that Norm it's become so rare we're
almost like one of the few people left
in the world who's like promoting this
but this is the way it's always been and
it's healthier for society so are you
within your legal limits now that in
this situation where the doctor said
look I'm I'm not wearing it are they can
they go ahead and get fired because it
is are they legally no legally they've
been fired there's they have people have
been fired but no they're you're within
your legal limits it's against the law
and in fact there was just a recent uh
court case uh that that they won where a
teacher who said I refuse to use the
chosen pronouns of the student because
it's against my religious beliefs she
was fired from the school and then they
went to court and they reinstated her
and they had to pay the school had to
settle with damages of ninety thousand
dollars yeah right so she because they
knew she she the teacher was within
their their legal rights to say hey this
violates my religious right right so yes
you're within your religious right if
you say you know what there's another
teacher that I had
um High School teacher she's the only
one in the whole school who didn't put
up a pride flag in her classroom and uh
they put pressure on her and she says
I'm within my legal rights you put
pressure on me you do any action against
me you know what's going to happen it's
I'm gonna take you to court and I have
the right to do this so yes legally
Muslims and anyone else has the right to
resist and say I don't want to wear your
rainbow flag and I don't need to promote
your agenda and I don't have to use a
particular pronoun or whatever it is
legally so yes we're within our rights
that's very important to know because
most people think because there's a gang
mentality you've got the whole staff
ganging up on you all the doctors
Physicians and you're like well this is
the law maybe but it's not it's not this
is just peer pressure it's peer pressure
I even checked it with uh one of the
Care civil rights teams and I said would
you guys take on a case and they're like
yeah yeah we'll take on the case I'm
like do we have the legal do Muslims
have the legal right to say we don't
want to partake in any of this stuff and
they said yes they absolutely are so
this is very clear this is a gem that
people can take away from this and
another thing is religiously like look
we know it's clear in the Quran that the
male is not like the female god almighty
is the only one without gender it seems
like people are trying to be God and
it's saying I'm not male or female right
when this is clear subhanallah this is
very very um you know trying times but
alhamdulillah if you stick to your Deen
you stick to the truth and truth as they
say shall set you free that's right
anything else uh before we conclude
that's it I mean the last thing I would
say I was uh we were talking about
um
you know
allying like supporting the conservative
Jews conser the other people of other
faiths who hold these values right
working with them you know sit down with
them say how can we work together we see
eye to eye on these issues
one of the reasons why Muslims are
afraid to do that I see some activists
and stuff they're afraid they're like
wait a minute I can't go to like someone
who is has been on Fox news or someone
who's like a a a conservative neocon or
you know has is like really hardcore you
know fundamentalist Christian or
something like that they hate our guts
so like
I they should be canceled right the
problem was with this cancel culture
Council culture is very problematic
right and what's happening is it's it's
Muslims have somehow
unintentionally Allied themselves with
leftist politics right with liberal
politics and partly it's understandable
because uh the Right started this
islamophobia and they started hating
Islam and all that stuff but what's
happening is when it comes to like
left-leaning Politics on on everything
we should not be aligning ours Muslims
should not align themselves with a
particular political movement
were neither leftist nor are we right
we're neither liberal nor are we
conservative we should go issue by issue
so when it comes to some social issues
or whatever it is we we might agree with
the Liberals when it comes to certain
Family Values when it comes to certain
moral things we're going to agree with
the conservatives so we should be
picking our alliances issue by issue as
Muslims and I think what the biggest
mistake that the Muslims have done is
they just Ally themselves with one of
these things because like oh we kind of
you know these people accept us a little
bit more so we'll Ally themselves we'll
Ally ourselves and we'll accept all of
the things that they stand for this is a
big mistake this is the biggest mistake
and I just want to remind people that
Islam is neither liberal nor
conservative according to American
political definitions so we need to
select we need to look at which group is
promoting which uh issue and find out
which one is more Islamic and Ally
themselves on issues not on candidates
and not on parties when you say that
term uh conservative I often think that
Muslims are actually not by the
political term him but just by what you
would think conservative means for
values and family values and stuff like
that yeah so if you go by that you can
say Muslims are more conservative than
the conservatives yes if you look at it
from that perspective yes indeed yes yes
indeed I'll tell you more we have a lot
a lot in common but that's right I like
that what you said you know thank you
very much again it's my pleasure man the
program man Allah
thank you guys for tuning in here to the
dean show again hit that notification
Bell subscribe every week for a new
exciting show and don't forget to
support us on a new project we get the
dean show into the dean Center we'll see
you next time and go ahead and visit the
deaneshow.com to get a free copy of the
Quran and we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalamu alaikum
if one person accepts Islam because of
you because of your effort it's worth
more than Holden yeah this is your
brother Abdul hawalda from Dallas Texas
I'm here in support of the dean center
it's a beautiful organization Masha
Allah doing hour in the U.S and they
have purchased a piece of land and
several building on it and we are
counting our brother and sister
throughout the US throughout the world
to be part of this magnificent project
it doesn't matter how much you give it
doesn't matter how much you donate what
matter we all participate inshallah may
Allah bless you thank you so much